quarter backs on me okay taking me
taking me taking me alright sure kind of
some nervous energy are excited about
seven on seven and I'm not gonna give a
big rah-rah speech you don't need it
hey you guys are ready to deal you guys
have studied hard you've prepared well
and you're really really flippin good
okay she's you have a lot of conference
today should be fun
you should just let it rip I can promise
you 12 through 18 I mean it is splitting
hairs literally how close this is who's
going to the opening circuits fun we
hear it we say it we believe it but
can't see the effect
and games online you can see in a
person's eyes it's noticeable the if
they make the players around them better
be effective welcome to the in Factory
was a not recruited out of high school
yeah I want to be you guys I want to
come to the Kent like this and get some
exposure but we just didn't know what to
do and I guess it was good enough and
you got to be on the practice field
first and leaving last so you're kind of
screwed so you better help your benefit
through the beautiful thing about elite
eleven is every year brings back these
epic camp counselors I mean it was Aaron
Rogers back in the day Mark Sanchez even
Carson Palmer sharing their story
sharing their path some guys let's max
max Brown played quarterback at SC fleas
guys I haven't met yet specifically when
Max was talking I found Tate Martel's
eyes I'd the fairytale high school
career and then I got to college and
that wasn't necessarily the case you can
tell his mind was getting ready to
explode make sure you guys are looking
at schools that you're gonna want to go
to school at not just play ball I just
wanted to go to a place I want to play
early I want to be the first guy right
when I walk it and you know now I want
to I want to go to a school that has
tradition I want to go to school that
you know is gonna build me as a person
as a player and gives me the best
opportunity regardless if I'm playing as
a freshman or from a redshirt senior I
like Davis Webb's speech I kind of
thought that that got hummed me a little
bit kind of like how he had to work his
way up some guys they don't get their
chance don't get their opportunities put
their head down be a bad teammate you
know two ways you say the same or you
get better I didn't get the top 11 out
of high school I'm still pissed about
that
and I'm dead serious look at my face now
I still think about that every single
day when I wake up because max Brown did
but I work my butt off and I carried
that chip still today football will
always be here we won't hear about
deshaun Watson and his mother you know
he's not so much of an extrovert he's
you know he's quiet he's to himself so
just hear him open up a little bit was
really special fifty years old you know
single parent mom four kids and my mom
caught me in the room and telling me
that you know she has tongue cancer you
gotta take care of my younger brother
younger sister you know work side jobs
or the football and not the school they
help you know my mom take care of the
bills and so what I had to do is is kind
of grow up fast and the reason I am the
person I am today because of that reason
that's just an incredible story you know
it's honestly it's like if you were put
in a situation that would you be able to
do the same thing know how to manage
adversity when it hits you all the new
kids they had a lot of success early on
in life and in digit Spanish here I
think I said I think I believe I faced
most everything that most people have in
their life and this is a young man who
had recently lost his father an imagine
being a big shot in high school football
all of a sudden the man in your life
somebody you looked up to who wasn't
there my grandmother called me she was
like your dad's really sick he had beat
Zelda for me and I went over there for
the first time it seemed and I broke
down because I never seen him like that
every time I look at the satellite he
always give me a thumbs up and his smile
and I would that would get me going you
can tell that this young man is still
processing a loss but processing it in
an extremely positive way
I liked the Shawn Kaiser story having to
just step up and be the guy I was a
backup quarterback to two great Heisman
Trophy candidates who were very good
guys and I truly went in everyday trying
to prepare as if it was my time to step
in and be Notre Dame's quarterback so
with that I think that the lessons I can
share with you guys from my experiences
truly prepares if you are the person you
want to be not the person you are it's
impactful because who they are in their
current circumstances and who they were
just a few years ago but to me equally
important they're affirming everything
we've done with them saying hey and
everything you're about to get trust me
you're gonna use it all because this
next part of your journey is way
different than you think it's gonna be
kind of knew who one through eight were
they kind of distanced themselves but we
saw to get 9 10 11 12 and there were
probably nine guys ten guys competing
for those spots so if you learn a lot
through seven on seven it becomes a
culmination of all the learning they've
gotten that week and can they piece it
all together
what is up perfect here we go we're
rolling go
touchdown
that's now great bro come on D worse
than the law
my god hey that happens it happens wish
your wipers wipe it off whoa
great ball
put them in this pressure cooker
situation that's on me you can really
see who's ready for it at the next level
but you can also accelerate the process
with a guy like Miles Brennan who's
grown tremendously and is has taken his
game to the next level with seeing this
great competition at this event
yeah that's Diddy get up in definitely
dated to test your in Tison to test it
to see if you had it I wanted to show
the people that you know I have it
myself
good job okay right just stand one let
one happen right like that one happened
like you got off at too quick his wife
nope got it got it got it
stealing ice throw Jonathan nice throw
nice throw Jonathan Lewis got a huge arm
he's intimidating physically and he's a
learner like he just has sponge he wants
to know more he wants to get better he
wants to be refined
Jonathan working that to that that to
that unless that's stealing
steal unless it's absolutely still okay
I'm a really disciplined kid enough
that's what my parents like raised me on
my parents they're both from Jamaica
each year we go back to Jamaica and you
stay with my great-grandmother Jamaica
is not like wealthy they're really like
poor it's really eye-opening like how
fortunate we are to live in America and
so when I'm old I'm gonna go back and
try to help him up a little they take
him back to Jamaica to remind him where
they came from to remind him that things
in life aren't given to you things in
life are earned I think this young man
is gonna have Jamaica cheer inform and
potentially the rest of the country
Oh Cam Newton's 65 to 45 Jonathan Lewis
can boo that guy
right place and his mental side of the
game catches up with all his physical
ability his discipline and his work
ethic
I go
hey that's a that's funky hopefully I
can keep pushing keep performing on the
field and performing in the workouts and
really show what I can do nice good job
hunter yeah
spread right option yep I wanted to come
out and for my best and just do the best
I could with you know the situation I
was given the opportunity I was given so
hopefully I'll be able to get invitation
to girls open and move on the biggest
standouts for to wait and Tommy DeVito
to guys that absolutely ripped it they
were near-perfect in there seven on
sevens and it wasn't just that they
completed every ball and score a bunch
of touchdowns they did it exactly the
way they were taught to do it last night
I really studied my playbook a lot just
to make sure I got everything down but
the fact that I went out and did it on
the field for seven on seven really made
it just fun
all the whole works paid off now I mean
now I'm just trying to get the opening
next step and actually be in the elite
11 time time Tommy was on the outside
looking in but I think that little he's
always played with that little chip on
his shoulder
vaulted him in four shirt lock lock him
in
tako
- it technically had a perfect day in
seven-on-seven
the way he lives his life and the
passion that he has I feel like all of
that comes out in every ball that he
throws my expectations when I came to
the eleven was to compete with the best
it's just an amazing journey to have
come this far in only three days
not too many kids from boy you get this
opportunity and platform to perform at
such a high level quarterbacking ice
touch riff la sua
it'll give Hawaii kids just a
realization that if cool can compete
with the best of the best at they'll eat
11 you know why can't I attaboy too huh
good cool way to go babe good group man
really good girl I am incredibly proud
of the screw
we've asked as much of from you guys as
we've asked anybody over the course of
this journey we've been on Elite 11 you
guys have answered the bell this by far
is the best group of arms but but people
I mean I could not believe sending those
interviews yesterday guys owe me way
from me at this age I saw Peyton Tom
Brady drew brees but those are some Hall
of Famers so think about what went into
these guys hearts and their minds to get
to the status they're at today all right
you got a long way to go but boy you got
a huge jump start we arrived at the the
end of the camp and man what a three
days Brian wants to talk about we've
made some changes this year explain that
sure so we all know name of the event
League 11 quarterback competition
started in 1999 we love the name of lead
11 but just like the Big Ten Conference
loves their name they now have 16 teams
and the big 12 now has 10 teams but they
had great tradition I had great equity
in that name like we do in elite 11 so
at the opening we're gonna have the
elite 11 MVP plus the elite 11
quarterbacks so we'll have 12 in gold
but it's how we figure this up it's good
work
so now ma'am how'd you feel this morning
after your whirlwind three days better
than you think
right yeah they will handle everything
pretty well freaka this morning sucker
it'll probably hit me here in a couple
hours oh this is hit a wall and passing
like all of us trust me
we had combat interviews and the one
question we asked everyone was we're
starting a program today you cannot
choose yourself which of the 23
quarterbacks
which one would you choose a certain
program today you were by far the one
that the rest of the group said so this
group thinks very highly of you not just
as a player but as a person - we feel
equally as high about you so we're here
to invite you to the opening and welcome
to part of the elite 11 this competed
amazing here when he's been with us and
he we had a great first leg in the state
track meet as well so excited to see him
finish up this process so mom are you oh
I'm sorry
and so ours how'd you feel like you did
today very well very well yes sir two
bad throws but no it's gonna happen new
eyes perfect so can you talk us through
one of them um will show gia we got it
yeah so just talk us through what's the
what's the play is it Smith yeah yeah
yeah I just tried forcing it maybe I
should have waited a window could have
done that this will follow up to our
combine interview with you you promised
that she'd make the 11 and you did you
didn't try but he's I think is on the
verge of it because he like all these
other kids they've been idolizing the
quarterbacks that have gone before them
and miles just like the other
quarterbacks it's true joy and elation
when he got word that he's in bleeped
alone you stamped your place in the 11
and you're gonna have a blast look after
damn sure good
so we got our twelve going to Oregon
right Pam yeah we're gonna announce the
twelve they're going to the opening but
then they're still competing to become
the MVP it's good to be the 11 but MVP
no matter what that's my goal
with a high school level when in the
league 11 MVP is the highest you can do
so I'd be unreal to do that thought
between the pro day workout the combine
interviews I knew the kids as well on
the field as I did off the field better
than in any other year just appreciate
the way they competed they're all elite
but also you can only take so many to
the open
you